[Musik]
die richtigen Fragen bei Bild herzlich
willkommen wen hätten sie vor genau
einem Jahr gewählt wenn sie gewusst
hätten wie hoch heute ihre Gasrechnung
und ihre Stromrechnung ist wenn sie
gewusst hätten dass in diesem Winter
sehr viele Deutsche frieren müssen dass
Deutschland Blackouts drohen haben wir
die falsche Regierung die richtigen
Fragen jetzt an zwei Fraktionschefs im
Bundestag den fDP-Fraktionschef
Christian dürr und den linken
Fraktionschef Dietmar Bartsch zu Gast
der SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete Ralf
Stegner Joachim Steinhöfel Anwalt
neuerdings auch bildkolonist und bei uns
Michael Schäfer er ist hauptamtlich
Energieberater und außerdem
ehrenamtlicher Katastrophenhelfer im
Ahrtal
Autogas Brot das Leben ist so teuer
geworden dass ich selbst die die jeden
Tag arbeiten das ganz normale Leben
nicht mehr leisten können in Italien ist
das Ergebnis eine wutwal gewesen und
genau das kann in Deutschland auch
passieren sagt Friedrich Merz den ich
heute zum Gespräch getroffen habe
das Wahlergebnis in Italien zeigt zu was
die Wählerinnen und Wähler bereit sind
wenn eine Regierung versagt oder eine
Regierung die politische und
Unterstützung nicht mehr bekommt die sie
braucht ich sehe mit größter Besorgnis
das Ansteigen von links und vor allem
rechtsradikalen Parteien und
insbesondere einer Partei in
Ostdeutschland und das bleibt jetzt
nicht mehr allein in Ostdeutschland das
geht auch nach Westdeutschland wir sehen
das zum Beispiel die AFD mittlerweile in
Niedersachsen anfängt zweistellig zu
werden in den Umfragen das sollte
eigentlich dieser Bundesregierung ein
wirklich deutliches Warnsignal sein ist
das ein Warnzeichen für Sie Herr Stegner
das heißt eine Wut Wahl in Italien wie
in Italien weil sie so schlecht regiert
sowas von scheinheilig die haben
geworben für die Region in Italien der
Weber csu-vizad für diese
Rechtsregierung erworben weil die haben
das nötig was zu sagen dass wir
aufpassen müssen dass die Probleme
gelöst werden die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht abgeholt werden von denen die
Ängste verwalten das stimmt aber ganz
bestimmt nicht mit solchen Vorschlägen
wie sie von der Union kommen die haben
vorgeschlagen dass wir das boykottieren
im Frühjahr hätten wir das gemacht
hätten wir jetzt schon machen aber zur
Sicherheit also das sind die falschen
Ratgeber in der Ampel Koalition arbeiten
wir zusammen an Lösungen die für die
Bürger erträglich sind dass sie das
bezahlen können das ist nicht einfach
haben wir übrigens natürlich auch nicht
wissen können dass das so kommt aus
werden wir hinkriegen und bei der
alternative muss ich ehrlich sagen sind
die Leute bestimmt froh was Sie gewählt
haben von März sagt Herr dürr sie
versagen in der Regierung Herr Stegner
versagt sie versagen ihre chefsversagen
und das drei treibt die Leute an die
Ränder auch in Deutschland es wird
genauso kommen ja bei der klaren
Abgrenzung gegen Rechts da sind wir uns
hier eine Runde denke ich einig da ist
auch die Opposition gefordert das wird
Herr Bart wahrscheinlich nicht anders
sehen und ich glaube das sollte Herr
März auch so sehen das betrifft
einerseits natürlich aus Deutschland
aber insgesamt Deutschland gar keine
Frage wir haben zum Glück ein anderes
Wahlsystem in Deutschland das ist nicht
so irratisch das ist ein
ausgleichenderes Wahlsystem
ja zum Glück weil wir stabilere
Regierungen haben 1 und 2 bin gar nicht
so sicher lass mich ganz kurz den Punkt
nochmal weil bei stegners andeutete und
da ist Herr Merz auch in der
Verantwortung herr Weber von der CSU als
führender Kopf der europäischen
Christdemokraten aus Deutschland der hat
ja für diese Regierung die dort jetzt
gewählt worden ist jedenfalls für Teile
davon aktiven Wahlkampf gehabt
deswegen muss man aber nur auf das ist
jetzt genau
ich habe nur eins festgestellt dass zwei
Politiker zu Wort gekommen sind und zwei
Mal sind textbausteinkästen ausgekippt
wo man all die Phrasen hört wie alles
nur 100 mal gehört haben also Italien
hat eine rechte oder sehr Rechte
Regierung gewählt hatten wir das zum
ersten Mal da war Pepe Grillo irgendein
Clown der ist da sechs Monate an der
Regierung gewesen wir hatten
Linksextremisten in Griechenland ich
weiß nicht ob die Aufregung da genauso
groß war Italien wählt weil sie
unzufrieden sind auch ist auch bereit
extreme Extremisten zu wählen aber in
sechs Monaten wahrscheinlich in 12
Monaten ist die Regierungschefin nicht
mehr dieselbe wie heute und wenn Brüssel
jetzt anfängt zu sagen ihr habt falsch
gewählt wir nehmen euch das Geld weg
ist das ein größer eine größere Gefahr
für die Demokratie als das Wahlergebnis
von wähle in einem meiner freien
Demokratie wie Italien die Menschen
haben diese Regierung gewählt jetzt oder
diese Frau Meloni gewählt in Italien
weil sie versagen festgestellt haben bei
allen anderen Herr Bartsch sehen Sie
solche Tendenzen hier bei der hier
sitzenden Ampel ich glaube das kann man
so nicht ganz vergleichen Italien ist
Italien da gibt es sicherlich viele
Probleme und deswegen haben die Menschen
so entschieden das war auch eben ein
Mangel der vergangenen Regierung in
Deutschland haben wir riesige Probleme
ich finde das im Moment sehr schlecht
regiert wird das ist meine feste
Position und das ist auch die Gefahr
wenn man sich nur anschaut nächste Woche
wird der Bericht zum Lage der deutschen
Einheit veröffentlicht und dann schaut
noch mal wie viel Zufriedenheit es gibt
aber Zufriedenheit 26 Prozent ist nicht
so dolle also da haben wir richtige
Probleme ich will zugestehen das konnte
man nicht ahnen als sie noch
fortschritt-koalition hießen da war
weder der Krieg in der Ukraine absehbar
noch die Inflation absehbar aber so ist
das nun mal wirklich eine Regierung da
und da sieht man im Moment natürlich ein
Chaos in der Regierung man muss sich nur
das Thema gaspreisumlage anschauen wenn
ich das sehe also jetzt habe ich mir
nicht vorstellen können wenn ich sehe
was für Veränderungen die sitzen jetzt
hier nicht am Tisch aber zum Beispiel in
der Linkspartei wir können gerne lieber
Linkspartei reden ist aber heute nicht
Thema aber können wir gerne eine Sendung
machen also bin ich auch gerne bereit zu
streiten aber das ist nicht der Punkt
wenn ich mir überlege sitzt nicht am
Tisch die Grünen vor Tische und ich
gucke mir die Wahlplakate an und dann
sehe ich drei Monate später 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen das war da
stand was ganz anderes auf dem Plakaten
ich kann mir anschauen was Robert Habeck
an Anfang des Jahres gesagt hat was
heute passiert es ist Chaos das muss man
so zusammenfassen ich kann nur hoffen
dass nach der niedersachsenwahl sich die
drei Parteien in irgendeiner Weise
wiederfinden und zumindest dann
gemeinsam agieren denn jetzt gibt es nun
gegeneinander sie sind habe ich gerade
schon gesagt Energieberater das heißt
sie arbeiten im Moment an der Basis dort
wo die hohen gasabschläge die hohen
stromabschläge gerade völlig werden
beraten dann die Menschen völlig
verzweifelt was hören Sie dort speziell
im Ahrtal wo Sie tätig sind nach allem
was dort passiert ist Flutkatastrophe im
Moment über diese Regierung ja das
schlimme ist eigentlich es wird auch
hier wieder davon gesprochen von dieser
immer lösen gasumlage ja wenn man sich
den Unsinn anhören muss das hat mit der
Gasanlage gar nichts zu tun die
gasumlage werden die geblieben wäre wäre
alles gut gewesen hätte wahrscheinlich
auch wieder gerne bezahlt muss das der
Gaspreis ist mittlerweile für achtfacht
hat eine über 40 centlich ich habe zum
Beispiel noch ein Gaspreis mit 5,3 wir
liegen jetzt über 40 Cent immer Strom
liegen wir weit über 70 das ist das
eigentliche Problem die gasumlage ja das
kriegt jeder noch irgendwie bezahlt wo
ist die Strom und Gaspreise die wir
haben die keiner mehr bezahlt und zwar
keine arbeitender auch kein
Mittelständler mehr das ist vorbei das
wird nicht funktionieren und deshalb ist
das tatsächlich ein Versagen auch was
der abartsch gerade eben sagte das hätte
man nicht voraussehen können ich habe
den Satz Italiener sehen heute dies
Wahlergebnis wo ein riesen Aufschrei
hier ist können Sie das ein bisschen
verstehen ja natürlich ist es nahezu
wird sie die Menschen sind unzufrieden
ja das wird bei uns auch passieren
jetzt das Problem dass die Gaspreise bei
den Leuten noch nicht angekommen sind
alles noch nicht alle angepasst weil
jeder hat unterschiedliche lange
Verträge und lange Laufzeiten aber das
kommt und wenn es kommt trotz Nippel
dick weil die Leute werden auf die
Straße gehen und werden dann auch
hoffentlich mal zeigen dass es so
einfach nicht funktioniert das was hier
gerade passiert ist wirklich ist
unmöglich genauso kommen sagt der
Schäfer Stegner können Sie
selbstkritisch sein einen Moment können
Sie einmal sagen wie groß ist die Schuld
ihrer Regierung wie groß ist die Schuld
ihres Kanzlers daran dass die Gaspreise
unbezahlt geht nicht um Schuld es geht
darum dass wir in der Situation haben
mit Krieg mit Pandemie mit Inflation die
gelöst werden müssen wir werden am Ende
von dem gemessen was ihr gelöst wird
haben daran arbeiten wir es man kann
überhaupt nicht davon reden das ist
schon zu Ende sein sondern wir sind
mitten da drin wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass im Winter die Preise bezahlt werden
können das werden wir auch hinkriegen
und ich kann also wenn ich die Sprüche
höre von denen die das was sie beklagen
selbst herbeiführen und gar keine
Alternativen zum Beispiel Herr märz oder
eher irgendwas
müssen wir das Lösen ich finde die
gasumlage nicht die Lösung die wird auch
nicht so kommen nach meinem Eindruck
daran wird gearbeitet werden sind halt
jetzt unbezahlbar und sie sagen wir
machen im Grunde das bestmöglich nein
sie sind noch nicht da und wir werden
aber sie der Kern der Belastung wird
jetzt kommen wir müssen zwei Dinge tun
wir müssen erstens für die
Versorgungssicherheit Sorgen das ist
schon mal ein großer Schritt nach vorne
die gastspeicher war nämlich leer die
sind jetzt voll wir haben kaum noch
Prozent Anteile der Geistlichen aus
Russland zwar vorher auch anders haben
also die Versorgung gesichert dass der
erste Punkt der zweite Punkt dafür zu
sorgen dass die Sie bezahlen können die
die niedrigen normalen Einkommen und die
Betriebe nicht kaputt gehen daran wird
gearbeitet zwischen drei verschiedenen
Parteien die unterschiedliche Programme
haben die auch unterschiedliche
Wahlprogramme machen das bestmöglich aus
ihrer Sicht und wir werden am Ende
gemessen und wir werden am Ende dann
gemessen und natürlich wird Politik wenn
sie so gemacht hat hat auch Fehler wer
würde die nicht machen aber da gilt eben
auf 100 Besserwisser kommt ein besser
mache und ich höre weit gehen die
Besserwisser reden die gar keine
Verantwortung haben wir haben sie wir
werden sie lösen und Sie werden das am
Ende sehen wir werden nicht Verhältnisse
kriegen wie in Italien und ich muss auch
ehrlich sagen Demonstration auf den
Straßen teilweise von rechts außen oder
wenn ich den ein oder anderen leider
auch von anderen Seite höre kann ich nur
sagen das löst kein einziges Problem der
Menschen kein einziges und wir müssen
Probleme lösen dafür sind wir da und das
wird am Ende was sollen nicht auf die
Straße gehen man soll nicht
demonstrieren jedenfalls nicht sich
gemein machen mit Leuten die am Ende zum
Beispiel diese Rechten sind ja nicht wie
Demokraten sondern Faschisten sind das
aber es sind ja nicht alle die auf die
Straße nein
nicht zusammen tun habe ich gesagt das
ist der Punkt das heißt eine extra
Demonstration oder zu Hause bleiben
rufen Sie auf zu Hause zu bleiben
dass man das da zu glauben ist macht
Sinn dass auf die Straße zu treiben weil
man vielleicht das erreichen kann die
haben das ja angedeutet dass man hier
aus dem Amt gibt auf dieser Art was wird
nicht gelingen wir werden die Probleme
lösen müssen und daran werden wir eine
Demokratie gemessen aber spielen Sie
sich angesprochen mit den Menschen nicht
gemein machen die da im rechtsextremen
Lager auf die Straße gehen also lieber
zu Hause zu bleiben nein das sage ich
nicht lieber zu Hause bleiben
also ich sage ganz klar dass
Demonstrationsrecht ist ein ganz schönes
gutes verfassungsrechtliche schützpunkt
aus Ende und ich ich wünsche mir dass
möglichst viele Menschen natürlich auch
Druck auf der Straße machen und
natürlich demokratischen Druck weil ich
glaube dass bisher falsche Entscheidung
getroffen worden sind natürlich also ich
meine Stimme zwar die Gasspeicher sind
jetzt voll aber zu welchem Preis dass
der Preis so hoch ist hat natürlich mit
deutscher Einkaufspolitik zu tun ist
alles gekauft worden was bei drei nicht
auf dem Baum war die Heizung gar nicht
mehr auf und die haben die Abschläge
jetzt bezahlen das zu bezahlen da können
sie sagen die gaspeicher sind voll das
ist auch gut aber jetzt müssen die
Abschläge bezahlt werden ja das ist toll
gar nicht zu Ende ich sage erstmal die
Gasspeicher sind voll das ist erstmal
ein Ergebnis was Versorgungssicherheit
garantiert allerdings sind die Preise
deshalb so gewaltig hoch ein
Riesenproblem zweitens wir tun immer so
als wenn das unsere Speicher sind glatte
Lüge die Speicher gehören nicht
Deutschland sondern die gehören
Unternehmen und wohin dieses Gas geht
ist völlig offen also ich meine Bayern
wird versorgt mit österreichischen
speichern ist aber auch gar nicht mein
entscheidender Punkt der entscheidende
Punkt ist was tun wir und das ist
richtig nicht die gaspreisumlage ist das
Problem sondern der Gaspreis und der
preiswerten Problem und für viele
Menschen die die Nahrungsmittelpreise
Problem deswegen muss man alles tun dass
die Inflation wieder in geordnete also
man kann als Staat Deutschland kann
nicht Schalter umlegen ist die Inflation
geringer aber wir sehen doch zum
Beispiel bei den gasbreiten warum sind
die in Frankreich niedriger deutlich
niedriger warum sind die in Spanien
niedriger deutlich niedriger ja weil es
dann gaspreisdeckel gibt warum gibt es
den in Deutschland nicht ich wünsche mir
dass die Koalition noch dahin kommt ich
habe mit großer Freude gehört von Herr
Linda dass der am Sonntag sagt
gaspreisdeckel finde ich eine gute Idee
Hauptsache kommt schnell was sagt das
über das Land aus Herr steinhöfe dass
Menschen in Deutschland von einem Jahr
unvorstellbar frieren müssen in diesem
Herbst Winter zwei Gründe ich glaube
einen Vorwurf kann man der aktuellen
Ampel nur bedingt machen jeden Fall aber
kann es dem spd-anteil der Ampel machen
nämlich die die Struktur der
Energieversorgung ist hier seit Schröder
und über die merkeljahre an die Wand
gefahren worden in völlig ihrer Weise
ergänzt durch die ideologischen
Positionen der Grünen der erste Schritt
der richtig gewesen wäre nach dem
nachdem man gesehen hat Putin marschiert
ein wer zu sagen wir verlängern die
Laufzeiten der Atomkraftwerke und für
Deutschland bin ich wieder optimistisch
wenn die Grünen Ideologie nach hinten
stellen und sagen wir müssen nicht nur
die die Laufzeiten verlängern sondern
wir müssen die neueste Generation von
Atomkraftwerken in Deutschland bauen
wenn dieser Schritt möglich wäre in
diesem Land dann könnte man wieder sagen
da geht was stattdessen importieren wir
Atomstrom aus dem Ausland es ist eine
derartige absurde Situation die man
eigentlich am besten mit den Leuten
bildlich sich vor Augen führt die sich
auf der Straße festkleben wir haben
überhaupt und dann fangen Sie noch das
Gendern an wenn Sie abtransportiert
werden die Leute wissen nicht mehr wo
die Prioritäten sind und eins noch zu
Ihnen Herr steht sie haben eben gerade
versucht mir irgendwelche Vorwürfe zu
machen ich habe lediglich gesagt Italien
wählt Protest und die rechtsradikale
Regierung ist in einem Jahr wieder weg
sie haben doch eigentlich von dem was
Sie gesagt haben nur das bestätigt die
alte Erkenntnis wenn man der SPD schaden
will lädt man sie entweder in eine
Talkshow ein oder man sieht jetzt sie
deutlich widersprechen
und gesagt zu den Menschen zurück an dem
animepunkt
mich interessiert an der Frage ob die
Regierung tatsächlich alles tut denn der
Vorwurf ist ja sagt der Steinwürfel auch
Steinhöfel auch das hätte man relativ
schnell lösen können längere Laufzeit
Atomkraftwerke grüne Ideologien
zurückstellen und schon werden die
Preise auch weiter runter das heißt der
Vorwurf lautet ja und das sagen viele
Menschen im Moment auf der Straße sie
tun nicht alles um die Preise zu senken
hat eins Ursache Wirkung nicht vergessen
weil das geht mir gerade ein bisschen zu
grob schlecht dich hin und her wenn ich
das offen sagen darf Ursache Wirkung
nicht vergessen Ursache sitzt im Kremmen
die Tatsache dass in Deutschland auch
falsche Entscheidung getroffen worden
sind und ich könnte das als ehemalige
Opposition mir leicht machen sollen
andere
Weise aber das mache ich ja gar nicht
sondern ich akzeptiere dass diese
Entscheidung getroffen worden sind man
hat auf russisches Gas gesetzt das war
expost Riesenfehler ohne jeden Zweifel
es müssen wir jetzt ausbügeln als neue
Regierung ganz genau und ein Punkt ist
richtig die Preise sind gigantisch hoch
übrigens in ganz Europa und deswegen
muss man zwei Dinge machen nämlich einer
Wurzel anpacken erstens die Preise
müssen nach oben das und nach unten
deswegen der Vorschlag einer
strompreisbremse darauf haben wir uns in
der Ampel schon geeinigt und der zweite
Vorschlag jetzt von Christian Lindner
den ich für richtig halte am Wochenende
in der Bild am Sonntag eine
gaspreisbremse vollkommen richtig aber
die Kombination muss zusammen sein mit
einer Erweiterung der Menge und ich will
jetzt keine ökonomisches Lehrstück hier
machen aber klar ist das hohe Preise ein
knappheitssignal sind wir müssen also
die Menge ausweiten wir fangen das jetzt
bei der Kohle an ich sage ganz ganz
offen mein Eindruck Sozialdemokraten und
Freien Demokraten geht das noch zu
langsam ich finde da müsste Herr Habeck
schneller sein die Kohle wieder ins Netz
zu bringen und als freier Demokrat sage
ich auch die drei Kernkraftwerke die am
Netz sind die sollten über den 31.12
hinaus weiterlaufen das ist das wo wir
zurzeit diskutieren ich hoffe er wird da
sehr schnell Entscheidungen treffen
letzter Satz Herr Weise unser Angebot
als FDP ist ja wir sagen
ordnungspolitisch kann man darüber
diskutieren wir sagen ja zu einer
gaspreisbremse jetzt erwarte ich vom
grünen Koalitionspartner dass er dann
auch ja sagt zur Laufzeitverlängerung
strompreisbremse wäre das was Ihre
Kunden ihre Kunden im Aartal erstmal
beruhigt dass man so wie bei der
sparda-garantie jetzt ein bisschen
Sicherheit hat wie damals bei Merkel
Steinbrück ich glaube gar nicht dass es
daran liegt ich glaube jetzt einfach in
den letzten 20 Jahren in der in der
gesamten Energie alles falsch gemacht
worden ist ja das ist also welche ich
glaube der Scholz unser Bundeskanzler
hat das mal vor der Wahl gesagt hat es
danach war ich eigentlich wieder
vergessen wir müssen uns erstmal die
Priorität draufsetzen das will da neue
Netze bekommen wir haben alte Netze die
diesen Strom zum Teil gar nicht
aushalten können das heißt deshalb auch
jetzt die Warnungen vor dem Blackout
wenn jetzt alle mal die Wärmepumpen
anmachen und die und alles was da so
jetzt mit Strom umgewandelt wird was man
man geht von Gas weg jetzt will man den
Strom ab aber wie muss ich warm also
scheißegal ich mache das jetzt ich mache
meine Heizung an ich mache meine Heizung
an und dann kommt irgendwann der Punkt
im Luftballon können Sie so lange
aufblasen bis er platzt wenn er geplatzt
ist dann ist vorbei dann ist er kaputt
ihre Kunden erwarten die noch von
Stegner dürr und Co dass sie diese
Probleme für Sie lösen absolut nein weil
man merkt diese Unzufriedenheit auch
ist ja auch jetzt so wenn man wirklich
mit dem Kunden mal da sitzt man macht
mal CHECK24 eurobox auf und wenn man
wenn man da gucken kann
die wissen alle der Preis ist
hochgegangen wenn sie dann aber mal
sehen wo der ist
dann sehen sie Gesichter sie sich sehr
stark verändern die werden sehr sehr
weiß und sehr sehr blass weil die Leute
massive Angst haben und wenn wir dann
nicht gegensteuern werden viel früher
schon ein sicheres die nur das Problem
der Regierung die jetzt hier ist das ist
auch schon die Vorgängerregierung
gewesen die alles falsch gemacht hat
seit Schröder damals ist einfach nichts
gemacht worden um die Netze wirklich mal
oder unseren Strom überhaupt mal perfekt
hinzubekommen überhaupt damit arbeiten
kannst
schneller gehen ich bin absolut sein ich
zeige Ihnen einmal was das aktuell für
die Stimmung in Deutschland bedeutet wir
haben zum Wochenende dreimal mit Hilfe
des Meinungsforschungsinstituts Insa
gefragt wie es um das Vertrauen in die
krisenbewältigungskompetenz der
Bundesregierung aktuell steht und da
sagen eben weit über 60% aktuell der
deutschen na da habe ich wenig Vertrauen
rein dass diese Regierung meine
Alltagsprobleme löst 30 Prozent sagen im
Moment noch da gibt es ein großes
Vertrauen über 64% eben geringes
Vertrauen und noch krasser wird es wenn
wir auf die einzelnen Minister gucken
wir haben einzeln abgefragt die
topminister der Bundesregierung ist das
aus ihrer Sicht die richtige oder die
falsche Besetzung für dieses Amt und da
gewinnt keiner dieser abgefragten
Personen in grünen Balken sondern schon
beim Kanzler sagt die Mehrheit das ist
eine Fehlbesetzung bei Christian Lindner
dem Finanz dem Finanzminister sagt die
Mehrheit ist eine Fehlbesetzung und
besonders heftig ist die sind die Zahlen
für Robert Habeck und für die
Verteidigungsministerin also Robert
Habeck mittlerweile auch die
überwiegende Zahl der deutschen die
sagen das ist eine Fehlbesetzung Herr
Steinhöfel sie haben Teil dieser
Regierung sozusagen mit ihrer Stimme
mitgewählt sie haben das darf ich sagen
haben sie gesagt FDP gewählt sind sie
enttäuscht von ihm naja das ist bei der
FDP ja eine ewige Geschichte von ihm bin
ich nicht enttäuscht weil die von ihm
nichts erwartet habe das meine ich jetzt
gar nicht so böse aber ich habe ja von
ihnen sie sind Fraktionsvorsitzender der
sie regieren nicht so
ja genau so dass sie bereits
ich habe Erwartung von denen die in der
Regierung sind so war das gemeint äh was
habe ich eine Frage vergessen ob sie
enttäuscht sind als FDP Wähler von dem
was geboten wird an fdp-politik wenn wir
uns wenn wir uns die die Zahlen da
gerade anschauen die wir gesehen haben
muss man natürlich einsehen dass das
Zahlen sind die jetzt so in einem das
ist im Momentaufnahme sagen Politik wenn
sie schlechte Zahl haben sagen Sie
Momentaufnahme die durch den Krieg
natürlich extremen bestimmte Richtungen
geschoben werden aber
ich finde es gut dass die andere regiert
weil ich es als unabdingbar erachtete
das Merkel und alles was für Merkel
steht von der CDU in die Opposition geht
denn diese Partei ist völlig verbraucht
sie hat regiert und regiert und regiert
und alle die
Positionen eingenommen haben die nicht
der Position von Frau Merkel gesprochen
haben die hatten praktisch keine Stimme
mehr in der Union jetzt haben wir mit
März gehofft das ändert sich es ändert
sich nichts er hat sich bei wüst und bei
Günther die beide schwarz grüne Tendenz
ganz klar dokumentieren untergehakt und
er ist doch derjenige der sich jetzt an
der Tendenz in der Partei unterwirft die
dafür wesentlichen mitverantwortlich ist
mit der SPD von Herrn Stegner für den
Zustand in dem wir uns aktuell befinden
da wähle ich doch nicht diejenigen die
den Mist angerichtet haben um den Mist
den andere zur Hälfte jedenfalls nicht
zu verantworten haben wegzuräumen es
gibt also keine Alternative außen rechts
und links gibt es auch keine Alternative
wobei sie sich wirklich mal fragen
müssen wie kann das angehen dass eine
Partei in einem derart cut auch so
fahren Zustand wie die AFD im
Ostdeutschland stärkste Partei ist das
sagt doch alles aus über das was die
Menschen die Menschen denken über die
Kompetenz derer die zur Lösung berufen
sind selbst bei ihnen im eigenen Lager
in der FDP regt sich mittlerweile
Widerstand einzelne Ortsverbände sagen
lieber lieber nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren hätte also einzelne
Ortsverbände haben immer auch
richtigerweise Kritik an der eigenen
Regierungsparteien das gehört zu einer
Demokratie dazu also ich bitte Sie das
wäre absurd wenn das nicht so wäre dann
würde ich mir das ist in jeder pleiter
erbarsch Herr Stegner alle wir könnten
Herr März auch einladen die würden alle
ein Lied davon singen das doch
vollkommen in Ordnung das gehört zu in
der parteilichen Demokratie dazu die
Frage ist doch wie löst man Probleme das
war jetzt eigentlich die Frage um diesen
in der in der Regierung ist und wie
viele da selbst schon passieren davon
wirklich politische Analysen oder waren
sie wollen die Menschen die was die
Leute wollen schon wissen ob das stabil
ist was sie da gerade bieten oder ob das
daran einziges Getränke und darauf
wollte ich gerade hinaus ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass wir für die zentralen
Probleme die Deutschland auch vor dem
September letzten Jahres vor der
Bundestagswahl hatte dass wir das vier
Jahre lang machen können Energie hätten
wir errang gewusst haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag einiges vereinbart ich
mach mal einen anderen Punkt
Einwanderung die Union hat über 30 Jahre
lang behauptet Deutschland sei kein
Einwanderung wir hatten Einwanderung in
die sozialen Sicherungssystem aber nicht
in Arbeitsmarkt das Drehen wir in der
Ampel gerade um an der Stelle
Thema planungsbeschleunigung an der
Stelle müssen wir wesentlich schneller
werden jetzt stellen wir einsfest wie
unter einem brenngras dieser Krise das
muss sofort passieren deswegen haben wir
gerade eine Reihe von Gesetzesform
natürlich würde ich mir wünschen dass
morgen gleich Deutschland reformiert ist
was für den letzten 16 Jahren falsch
gelaufen ist aber wir arbeiten daran
meistens der Probleme die Sie aktuell zu
tun haben trotzdem die Frage ob sie
permanent überhaupt noch wissen wohin
dieses Boot dieses regierungsboot gerade
steuert Einzelteile der FDP wie gesagt
sagen das funktioniert nicht mehr mit
dem Habeck lass da raus haben sie mal
mit dem Verband in Stralsund gesprochen
wir haben Kontakt natürlich auch zu
denen die Robert Habeck kritisieren und
ganz offen ein bisschen der Kritik habe
ich vorhin auch geäußert weil es mir
weil ich ist mir wünschen würde dass er
schneller ist an der ein oder anderen
Stelle ist auf gar keine Frage jetzt
einmal Hersteller busner aus dem FDP
Ortsverband in Stralsund ist bei uns und
kann uns einmal erklären kann Herrn Dörr
einmal erklären hier bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen warum sie das nicht
mehr mehr länger mittragen wollen mit
der Ampel airbuschen also warum soll
Herr Dörr jetzt nach noch nicht mal im
Jahr sagen das war's schaffen wir nicht
mehr dann habe ich Geburtstag ja guten
Abend Herr Dörr ähm erstmal vielen Dank
dass ich hier sein darf und schöne Grüße
aus Stralsund ich möchte erstmal noch
auf Herrn Stegner eingehen
gute Talkshow Logik aber das machen wir
nicht die Frage war ganz klar und ihr
sitzt also
was ich sehe ist die FDP kann sich in
dieser rot-grünen Regierung nicht
durchsetzen bedauerlicherweise das muss
man so hart sagen
wir hatten einen sehr klaren Slogan aus
Liebe zu Freiheit
und dazu sollten wir auch stehen
und unser Hauptproblem gerade ist doch
jetzt wir haben nicht nur die
radikalsten freiheitseinschränkungen der
Bundes der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ertragen müssen jetzt in
dieser Regierung das war noch radikaler
als alles was die große Koalition in der
corona-zeit beschlossen hat nein jetzt
müssen wir auch noch sehen wie die Ampel
70 Jahre lang
erarbeiteten Wohlstand vernichtet
innerhalb von nur zehn Monaten also wir
stehen gerade wir reden über
Blackouts wir reden darüber dass die
Industrie komplett kollabiert dass wir
eine Gaskrise haben der Mittelstand der
Bericht zusammen was wir hier da sehen
bei der Demo das waren Bürger für
Stralsund das waren CDU oder das waren
fdp-ler das waren sehr sehr viele
Unternehmer das waren Hoteliers das war
ein Restaurantbesitzer das war die die
HOGA die dort vertreten war das war auch
ein Bürgermeisterkandidat von der Linken
und der Bürgermeister Oberbürgermeister
aus Stralsund hat das als Privatperson
auch unterstützt
ist ein offener Brief geschrieben der
jetzt in die Konsequenz aus all dem was
Sie gesagt haben ziehen will und er sagt
das hat hier keinen Sinn mehr ich glaube
es ist vor kurzem hätten sie all das was
Herr Buschner gerade gesagt hat komplett
unterschrieben da wäre das ihr Text
gewesen sein damals nie gab es mehr zu
tun und das wird ja mehr als deutlich
nie gab es mehr zu tun als jetzt und
natürlich kann man als Partei sagen ich
will lieber keine Verantwortung aber in
so einer Krise zu sagen ich will keine
nein ich bin in die Politik gegangen um
was zu verändern und Verantwortung zu
übernehmen und ich würde die beiden
Beispiele die Herr buschener sagte das
gehört zu in der Partei ich Demokratie
vollkommen legitimer Corona Politik
unterschiedlich sein beim Thema
corona-politik wenn ich mir angucke dass
wir lockdowns hatten Schulschließung und
sonst was das gibt's alles nicht mehr
das hättest doch nicht gegeben wenn mit
Verlaub Herr Stegner die große Koalition
regieren würde sondern das hat mit die
FDP erreicht in dieser Koalition und
beim Thema Wirtschaftspolitik und
Steuerpolitik beispielsweise am Anfang
der koalitionspfannung ich habe den Teil
selbst verhandelt mit den Kollegen von
SPD und Grünen gab es null Möglichkeiten
auf der entlastungsseite jetzt gehen wir
durch den Deutschen Bundestag und machen
eine echte Steuerentlastung für 48
Millionen Steuerzahlern Steuerzahler das
macht schon Unterschied gerne würde ich
mich zu 100% bei einem durchsetzen bei
den Fragen gerade Laufzeitverlängerung
Energie wollen wir mal schauen aber man
kann auch am Ende des Tages nicht
erwarten dass man 100 Prozent geben wo
ist bei ihm aber gutes Punkt
wie viel Arbeitslose wie lange muss er
Habeck noch mit den Atomkraftwerken
warten wie tief muss sie corona-politik
von der Lauterbach gehen also wo ist der
schmerzlicherweise denn eine Sekunde den
Eindruck dass es Deutschland besser
gehen würde wenn sich jetzt eine
Regierung ernsthaft in so einer Krise
auslöst glauben Sie das kerke die
Kernkraftwerke würden verlängert in der
Laufzeit es würde gar nichts passieren
in Deutschland und das kann man
verantwortlicherweise nicht wollen
erstens und zweitens ich sage es nochmal
das interessantes verspricht genau das
der muss ja widersprechen
muss man sich zusammenraufen
da sagen die einen wir haben die
Mindestlohn eingeführt haben wir gemacht
wir haben ein Programm des
gesellschaftlichen Erneuerung wir werden
die Industriegesellschaft umbauen müssen
das werden wir zusammen besser können
als andere die das jetzt kritisieren
aber ist natürlich dürfen die Leute das
kritisieren natürlich haben die Angst
wenn Sie die Preise gibt unter anderem
die haben Angst da kriegt sich ausweitet
und das sind alles Themen mit dem was
man sich beschäftigen Kritik muss man
aushalten können aber am Ende ich sag's
ihnen noch mal wird die Regierung sich
als handlungsfähigerweise wir werden
Vorschläge machen
Entschuldigung wir haben momentan eine
Aufgabe zu lösen mitten in Europa wo die
meisten Menschen mir auf der Straße
sagen Gott sei Dank macht das der Olaf
Scholz bei euch und nicht der Herr Söder
oder der märz oder sonst irgendeiner von
denen also es ist auch ein Teil also
in der Schmerzpunkt wir vertiefen das
gleich wieder auch mit ihnen weil ich
deine Flotte aber wo ist der
Schmerzpunkt Herr Buschner hat den schon
erreicht hätte der Schmerzpunkt wäre
dann wenn ich ansatzweise das Gefühl
hatte dass die Opposition mit Verlaub
Dietmar Bartsch oder Friedrich Merz
bessere Vorschläge hätten ich kann das
nicht erkennen das Mark beatma gerade
sprechen
anhand der Union mal deutlich machen was
ist denn zur Zeit die Politik was liegt
denn die Union vor Herr Stegner sagt es
vor die Union hat vorgeschlagen also
Friedrich Merz in Person dass wir seit
März keine Gaslieferung das wäre
verrückt gewesen machen uns nichts vor
das wäre die Politik in Deutschland
gewesen würde Friedrich Merz regieren
werden jetzt massive wirtschaftliche
Schäden aber zwei erweise das darf ich
ausführen an der Stelle was mich gefragt
haben Herr Merz und seine Partei schlägt
jetzt vor wir müssen Nachfrage Politik
machen und die Nachfrage anheizen über
Abwrackprämien von Haushaltsgeräten
jeder Ökonom schlägt die Hände über dem
Kopf zusammen ich bin nur die
blumenökonom aber ein bisschen was
kennen mehr Dankeschön Herr Stegner mit
Verlaub also ich habe nicht den Eindruck
dass dort bessere Vorschläge kommen
trotzdem sehe ich uns in der Pflicht
ordentlich zu regieren gar keine Frage
da werden wir jetzt auch besser
hoffentlich in den kommenden Wochen in
dem wir konkrete energieentscheidungen
treffen aber da ist ja nicht ansatzweise
echter alternative erkennbar
alles in ihre Richtung eigentlich der
sagt genau ihren Text aber irgendwie
schlägt sich noch nie hier oder nein das
habe ich jetzt beim anders gehört sie
haben wenn man sich halt das Endergebnis
anguckt dann haben wir gerade einen
Wirtschaftsminister der den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen sagt ihr
macht mal bitte sechs Monate nichts ich
meine laufende Kosten oder sowas gibt's
halt nicht kenne ich nicht verstehe ich
nicht gar nicht zur eigenen Leben also
dass das ist gerade die Regierungslinie
und so was man sich die Leute nicht
anhören und es gibt da halt schon klare
Forderungen die etwa auch auf dieser
Demonstration genannt wurden das ist
neben dem Rücktritt der Regierung etwa
die Öffnung von Nord Stream 2 was ja
unter anderem auch Kubicki vorgeschlagen
hat die Aufhebung der Sanktionen Frieden
durch plomatie etwa man könnte auch
sagen Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen was
ja ein kleines Wunder die Diskussion
läuft aber natürlich tatsächlich auf der
Straße
war Hella von denen hier zu Gast und hat
genau das gesagt und hat auch gesagt
also ihn würden Neuwahlen jetzt nicht
mehr wundern wie sehen Sie das
ich glaube keine Sekunde an Neuwahlen
weil das ist nun mal so naja die Ampel
ist ein Jahr im Amt die werden ja
irgendwie behämmert fragen Sie mal die
Abgeordneten sie müssten ja eine
Mehrheit dafür kriegen das schließlich
aus also so chaotisch ist die Lage nicht
es gibt ganz viele Probleme ich finde
die machen riesige Fehler ich glaube
keine Sekunde an Neuwahlen aber nur was
macht er halt da muss man Argument
ich meinte natürlich
ich erwarte von der Regierung dass sie
die Probleme löst das ist die Aufgabe
und da sage ich es seit Monaten viel zu
wenig passiert denn die Beschreibung
stimmt doch einfach nicht nur was die
Gas und Strompreise betrifft sondern
auch was Nahrungsmittel was Inflation
all diese Punkte und da das eine
Überzeugung sehen die Menschen
Wirtschaftsminister ist hier mehrfach
genannt worden wenn ich mir allein die
ganzen Wolken anschaue seit Februar jede
Woche was anderes und da ist die benote
sehr gut aber die Anode die Substanz ist
verdammten und dann würde ich gerne mal
über die Dinge die vor Tische gesagt
sinnvolles Jahr es sind drei Parteien
natürlich ist es so dass man da sich
nicht eins zu eins durchsetzt was der
junge Kollege aus meiner Geburt statt
Stralsund sagt ist ja alles ganz
interessant aber die FDP hat erstens
nicht die absolute Mehrheit und wenn Sie
die absolute Mehrheit hätte wäre es fürs
Land auch nicht gut also das würde ich
jetzt anders
sagen ich erwarte dass diese Dinge die
angekündigt ist es so viel angekündigt
angeht dass sie angekündigt werden das
Ding gemacht wird
einmal einen Punkt muss ich mal sagen
wir reden über die entlastungspakete
drei an der Zahl und der wird von 95
Milliarden ich will die Teile jetzt gar
nicht überprüfen die stimmt nicht aber
ist egal aber über Nacht wurden 100
Milliarden für den sonderetat Bundeswehr
das ging über Nacht das wusste nicht
immer die Fraktion die waren alle
erstaunt als Olaf Scholz das sagte ich
sehe dass der Kanzler durch die Gegend
fährt und dann feiert das ein Schiff mit
LNG kommt im Dezember das ist eine
alberne Veranstaltung
ein bisschen also
sie sind weiter dran ich will nur ein
Haken sie haben gerade gesagt
dass das was die Bürger denken ja das
eine ist die haben macht er halt und das
ist ja ein wesentliches Argument dann
habe ich noch mal nachgefragt aber sagen
na ja das Vertrauen ist ja weg der
Menschen haben sie gesagt das ist ja
eine andere Frage nein entschuldigung
aber entschuldigen sie bitte ich ich
muss leider feststellen vor einem Jahr
ist genau ein Jahr her ist die
Ampelkoalition gewählt worden ich hätte
mir was anderes gewünscht ich habe
damals gesagt linke oder Lindner ich
glaube das stimmt im übrigen heute noch
es wäre eine ganz andere Politik aber
das muss ich zur Kenntnis nehmen und
immer wenn eine Regierung was falsches
macht kann ich nicht sagen Neuwahl wenn
dann wählen wir nach 14 Tagen neu
vertrauen wir haben das ja gerade
gesehen das ist schon spektakulär
Vertrauen genau
und sie haben vermutlich sogar recht
damit es ist völlig egal es ist völlig
egal ob das Vertrauen das ist völlig
egal wie gut die beiden Arbeiten die
machen halt einfach weiter herr Schäfer
die Fehler werden ja die Fehler macht
man jetzt jetzt schon seit Jahren der
Politiker ist jetzt nicht das eine was
wir jetzt gerade sehen sondern auch die
Jahre vorher schon wir haben so viel
Probleme in Deutschland über die nicht
geredet wird und die uns immer wieder
für die Füße fallen ja das ist nicht nur
die Energie sondern ist der Umgang mit
Russland da sagt man ja das hätte man
nicht erwarten können also wer sowas
sagt dass man das nicht erwartet hätte
erwarten können was Putin macht also ich
meine die Rede 2002 nehmen wir dann
Georgien dann nach der die Krippen
überfallen dann hat er die Verfassung
geändert dass ein dauerpräsident werden
kann wenn man da als Politiker Politiker
nicht merkt was da vor sich geht frage
ich mich was man überhaupt noch merkt
andersrum macht man denselben Unsinn mit
den Chinesen auch den hofieren wir auch
permanent noch was ist denn wenn der
Mann sagt so ich liefere euch nichts
mehr wo sind wir denn dann als Volk die
Politiker müssen langsam anfangen
darüber nachzudenken was denn da
überhaupt passiert die Chinesen ist noch
viel schlimmer was ist denn die
Konsequenz daraus sie können auch bei
großen Ländern die den Regierung uns
nicht gefallen sagen die beeindrucken
wir jetzt durch moralische reden ist
nein deutsche moralische reden ja wenn
ich mehr Europa bin ich mir Europa
vorstelle so wie Europa gedacht war
warum soll man die ganzen Sachen nach
China aus wir haben genug europäische
Länder die die Sachen auch hätten
übernehmen können also ich glaube das
wird mit dem Moral ja ja ist nicht der
Fall aber mein Wasser weg was die
moralischen reden angeht da kann man in
der Tat sagen dass Deutschland da ganz
weit vorne ist keine früheren
französischen Außenminister vielleicht
zusammen da sind wir die größten wir
fahren in der ganzen Weltraum halten
große Reden das fängt ja schon bei
Genscher an im ersten Golfkrieg
Deutschland bezahlt die Franzosen die
Italiener die Engländer die Amerikaner
können kämpfen denken wir mal an 2011
zurück Fukushima da ist in Japan ein
Unglück geschehen in Deutschland nicht
was hat Merkel gemacht über Nacht ein
paar Tage vor einer Landtagswahl die
gesamte Energieversorgung politisch auf
den Kopf gestellt diese Entscheidung
wurde getroffen wenn wir heute gucken
was die Leute am meisten stört das ist
meine Prognose ich laufe ja nicht rum
und halte Umfragen aber davon bin ich
überzeugt
die wissen auch dass die Regierung
nichts dafür kann was jetzt in der
Ukraine geschieht natürlich historisch
durch die durch die Kooperation mit
Putin McCain hat mal gesagt ein Mörder
ein Kriegsverbrecher ein Produkt des KGB
da unterschreibe ich jedes Wort und das
hätte man alles besser machen können
aber wie sich das jetzt eskaliert hat im
Februar dafür kann man die Regierung
nicht haftbar machen man muss nur
zweierlei erwarten dass sie das erkennt
und dass sie ganz klare Signale setzt
wir haben die Krise verstanden wir
können für gewisse Dinge nicht aber wir
tun was wir können und Handeln und das
wäre ich sagte schon
Laufzeitverlängerung und nicht nur eine
Rede halten Zeiten Wende die ich gut
fand und wie ein großer Sprung für die
SPD war mit Sicherheit so eine Rede zu
halten das war bemerkenswert von Scholz
aber dann müssen die Panzer auch
geliefert werden denn je mehr Panzer in
der Ukraine sind je mehr man diesen
tapferen Menschen hilft gegen diesen
Kriegsverbrecher die Krieg zu gewinnen
desto schneller sinken auch die
Gaspreise das ist doch ganz einfach
machen
bei vielen auf der Straße das hat der
Buschner gerade auch erinnert ist dass
es zuerst dass das Gefühl viele um die
Menschen dort in der Ukraine geht und
dann erst das Portemonnaie und dann erst
die Gasrechnung das ist wieder klassisch
das hat Italien beantwortet mit einem
Slogan Italy first gibt es eine solche
Tendenz hier in Deutschland ja die gibt
es glaube ich in erster Linie im Osten
Deutschlands aber es gibt ja und sowieso
diesen überbordenden Pazifismus hier wir
halten uns überall raus Waffen schaffen
keine Lösung doch wir sehen in der
Ukraine das Waffen eine Lösung schaffen
nämlich dass ein überfallen ist
gepeinigtes vergewaltigtes Volk sich zur
Wehr setzen kann gegen einen Aggressor
der Zweite Weltkrieg muss ich das
Beispiel bringen das Waffen und Militär
sinnvoll sein können
in dem ersten Teil gesagt haben
deswegen sind doch diejenigen die erste
Linie mit putinen zusammengearbeitet
sie widersprechen in fast allem was er
gesagt das ist mit der Atom sogar schon
ziemlich Rot-Grün ausgestiegen aus der
Turm Energie dann hat Merkel das
rückgängig gemacht hat uns Milliarden
gekostet für die Industrie und das nach
Fukushima das korrigiert worden das hat
die Mehrheit richtig von zweitens wir
unterstützen die Ukraine politisch
ökonomisch humanitär auch militärisch
aber wir wollen den Krieg auch nicht
ausweiten wir wollen keine Alleingänge
machen wir handeln gemeinsam mit den
Amerikanern Franzosen zusammen das
findet die Bevölkerung richtig anders
als sie das hier sagen und zu sagen wir
sollen vorangehen keinen Frieden sagen
sie Waffen schafft den Frieden in der
Ukraine sagt der steingriff Hövel mit
dem Streit machen wir gleich weiter Herr
Bartsch widerspricht auch nach einer
ganz kurzen Pause hier bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen bis gleich
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen in
hochkarätiger Runde heute abend Herr
Bartsch wir haben gerade über die Frage
gestritten schaffen Frieden Waffen wir
schaffen Waffen Frieden so rum in den in
der Ukraine ja oder nein ist es so wie
Frau Wagenknecht sagt dass wir links
dort Kriegspartei sind na gut ich meine
der Kanzler spricht vom Wirtschaftskrieg
Robert Habeck spricht von
Wirtschaftskrieg natürlich ohne die
Unterstützung von Deutschland von
anderen Ländern wäre die Ukraine nicht
in dieser Situation natürlich sind wir
letztlich Kriegspartei natürlich den
würde ich überhaupt nicht aber da hat
Herr Stegner übrigens sehr recht wir
müssen alles tun und Gott sei Dank sage
ich wird viel getan dass der Krieg sich
nicht ausweitet würde mal so locker mehr
Waffen mehr Waffen erstens entscheidet
das Deutschland nicht das wird immer
noch in Washington entschieden und
solange das da nicht klar ist werden
auch nie schwere Panzer geliefert ganz
klar zweitens die These stimmt nicht
glaub irgendwer dass je mehr Waffen sind
desto erst der Krieg zu Ende glaubt
irgendwer dass man vielleicht in Moskau
auf dem Kreml dann irgendeine Fahne
wehen lässt das ist absurd und es
besteht ein riesen Gefahr ich möchte
nicht dass diese Gefahr befördert wird
ich wünsche mir dass eine
Außenministerin eben wirklich nicht die
oberste Verkäuferin von Waffen ist
sondern alles versucht dass ihr
diplomatisch was hingehen wird immer
gesagt ja Putin Bilder gar nicht reden
ich kann nur feststellen sowohl beim
Getreideexport also beim
Gefangenenaustausch da hat es
funktioniert und es gilt der Spruch von
Helmut Schmidt lieber
100 Stunden verhandeln als eine Minute
schießen
Parteien sehr unterschiedlich bei
bartschalen zu Recht gesagt dass
natürlich eine Koalition aus
Sozialdemokraten grün und Linkspartei
heute ein ganz anderes Deutschland
geschaffen hätten als es mit der
Regierungsparteien der FDP dabei ist um
noch mal die Frage von vorn zu
beantworten
Fenster öffnen natürlich jederzeit doch
die Wahrheit ist putin will nicht
verhandeln also diese Unterstellung der
würde da sitzen und quasi auf dem Anruf
warten ist nicht richtig hat die babac
jetzt so nicht gesagt aber manche sage
ich meine in der in der insbesondere
übrigens spannender Weise in der rechten
Szene behaupten das ja die AFD ist das
muss man in aller Klarheit sagen da
manchmal wirklich ein Stück weit eine
Kolonne des Kremls auch bei den Debatten
im Deutschen Bundestag und ich finde es
fürchterlich denn dort sitzt der aggress
und wir sind in einer Situation in der
sich jeder Frieden wünscht zuallererst
doch die Menschheit teilweise das
allererster würde der jetzt handeln
komme so ich danke sage ist sofort
zuallererst die Menschen in der Ukraine
würden sich den Frieden wünschen und wir
alle doch gemeinsam aber richtig ist
dass diese Koalition auch dort eine
Zeitenwende gemacht hat und Hans
Dietrich Genscher ich bin davon
überzeugt hätte das gleiche getan
natürlich einen Kanal offen lassen gar
keine Frage aber in einer Situation wo
ein freies Land was ich in Richtung
Europa bewegen wollte aggressiv von
außen angegriffen wird
völkerrechtswidrig dass man da
unterstützt anders als es früher
Regierung getan haben wir liefern jetzt
Waffen in ein kriegs- und Krisengebiet
ist wirklich was anderes und ich bin mir
sicher vor dem Hintergrund der
Aggression aus dem Kreml hätte
Hans-Dietrich Genscher auch so
entschieden ist dieses nämlich total
offen nach Moskau werden sie in einigen
Wochen oder Monaten im Grunde dasselbe
sagen in der SPD wie Frau Wagenknecht
heute nein ich habe überhaupt nichts
gemein mit dem was da formuliert wenn
denn das sind Angriffskrieg und der
putin ist ein kriegsarbeiter und die AFD
ist nicht nur ein Stück weit sondern ist
komplett sozusagen die Stimme der
Autokraten aber ich glaube dass die
Unterstützung die wir der Ukraine geben
so gut sein muss es geht sie muss im
militärischen Teil gemeinsam mit den
Verbindungen gemacht hätten es muss
immer noch darüber geredet werden wie
man am Ende muss eine diplomatische
Lösung stillig und wir müssen auch
vermeiden dass der Krieg Ausfälle sagen
um 20 Menschen auf der Straße die zum
Teil noch so erinnern wie das bei ihren
großen Eltern war im Krieg wir haben die
Angst davor haben deswegen die Frage
übrigens
dafür kritisiert waren ich finde es gut
dass er das tut und natürlich ist das
schwierig dazu am Ende zu einer
Entscheidung aber man muss dahin kommen
ich kann mich gut Hinsehen als wir vor
ein paar Monaten langsam macht das doch
mit den Getreide bekommen liest das geht
nicht damit die Minen sind im Schwarzen
Meer dann schießen wir es ist gegangen
außer in der türkische Präsidentin und
nee kein Friedensstifter ist macht das
das wünsche ich mir eher von anderen ich
glaube die Logik immer mehr Waffen wird
am Ende des richten ist falsch ich tue
mich schwer mit dem Waffen liefern aber
ich habe das mitgetragen das im
Bundestag ja auch beschlossen dass wir
die Ukraine unterstützen müssen wir auch
tun aber es muss genauso Öffnung dafür
geben dass es am Ende gelöst hat denn
ich sage Ihnen auch eins die ganzen
Energieprobleme werden wir nicht lösen
und der Krieg ewig dauern ich habe eine
Sorge dass geschäftlichen Gesellschaften
sprechen mit amerikanischen
französischen Kollegen die sagen auf
Dauer Inflation hoch Energiepreise hoch
Flüchtlinge die Waffenlieferung führen
zunächst auf Dauer ist es sehr schwer
sie sehen in Italien jetzt schon
Rechtsregierung in Schweden leider auch
eine wer weiß was in Amerika passiert
das ist ein Problem und deswegen müssen
wir uns auch darum kümmern dass die
diplomatischen Kanäle wenn ich sie nicht
verstanden habe sagen sie ja mehr Waffen
damit wir nicht den Krieg verlängern
sondern verkürzen um dann ganz schnell
den Gaspreis wieder runterzukriegen
wir wollen den Krieg nicht ausweiten
hier tun wir das marschiert die Ukraine
morgen auf Moskau nein die würden doch
nie die ist schon die Frage ob sie in
die Krim gehen würden oder in die schon
2014 besetzen Gebiete das ist schon
fraglich wenn Sie das tun wäre das auch
alles völlig in Ordnung ausweiten wird
ihn Krieg jedenfalls nicht die Ukraine
und auch keine der Nationen die die
Ukraine unterstützen ob ich noch nicht
zweitens sie ist es aber dann ist das ja
klasse
vielleicht weiter den Krieg aus und dann
hätten wir ein und laufen weg hätte man
das mit nach dem Sudetenland nicht auch
anders machen lösen müssen oder
irgendein Senator oder 36 gesagt hat
wäre hätte ich bloß mit Hitler genau das
der zweite Punkt
sie haben gesagt in den USA wird
entschieden welche Waffen wir liefern
die us-botschafterin hat hier im
deutschen Fernsehen gesagt und auch auf
Twitter das muss jedes Land selber
entscheiden
Sie sich nur ganz kurz einmal vor was in
der Ukraine heute los wäre wenn der
Westen keine Waffen geliefert hätte wäre
das ein
vergewaltigungskonzentrationslager mit
Toten und Kriegsverbrechern das Land wer
der wird im Erdboden gleich gemacht das
wäre heute ohne Waffen immer wieder
angesprochen wurde Herr Dörr werden wir
das erleben dass wir in Richtung das war
auch die Kritik als Parteikollegen in
Richtung einer die Industrialisierung in
Deutschland laufen und das immer mehr
Firmen von den USA angezogen werden
immer wieder große deutsche
mittelständische Unternehmen die
reihenweise in die USA fahren
wir ja Dinge in der Politik ich habe es
vorhin angesprochen die Dinge die auch
sogar im Koalitionsvertrag stehen große
Strukturreformen in der Energiepolitik
andere Bereiche andere Bereiche kann man
fortsetzen das ist jetzt wie unter einem
brendlass klar dass das jetzt schneller
passieren muss das ist schwer genug
einige Dinge haben wir schon entschieden
Ausbau erneuerbare beispielsweise haben
wir gemeinsam entschieden ich füge hinzu
insbesondere beim Thema offshore bringt
auch mehr Stabilität in den Netze aber
ich sage in dieser Situation auch da
sind wir jetzt unterschiedlicher Meinung
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
für die Übergangszeit so also diese
strukturentscheidung treffen wir und das
Ziel ist natürlich deswegen ist die FDP
in der Bundesregierung dass dieses Land
ein wohlstandsland ist in dem das
soziale aufstiegsversprechen geht
natürlich bleibt selbstverständlich das
muss das Ziel sein aber das erreichen
wir nicht das sage ich ganz offen durch
Appeasement-Politik gegenüber Russland
das ist nicht von ganz schnell Ja oder
Nein schaffen sie das Herr Stegner Herr
Dörr ohne russisches Gas dieses
wohlstandsversprechen ja oder werden wir
schaffen ja natürlich wenn wir das
schaffen nur noch kaum noch den
Prozentanteil den wir hatten wir reden
hier Norwegen
wir hätten es eh machen müssen wir
hätten es doch eh machen unabhängiger ja
denn unabhängig von diesem
fürchterlichen Angriffskrieg aus dem
Kreml unabhängig davon war doch klar
dass diese krasse Abhängigkeit von
Russland energiepolitisch falsch war
Wert ist ohnehin diversifizieren müssen
glauben
dass wir das alle miteinander dass wir
das alle in Deutschland schaffen ohne
russisches Gas diesen Wohlstand zu
behalten er wir dürfen ja gar nicht
anders machen alles andere wäre ja so
kontraproduktiv es wird jetzt vorerst
keinen Frieden geben ja ich habe
entstehen oder auch schon gehört bei
Markus Lanzen auch die Frau Wagenknecht
ja wir müssen die die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen so viel wie wir irgendwie
nur können aus dem ganz einfach und es
gibt ein paar Möglichkeiten wieder zu
Gesprächen zu kommen das eine ist die
Bevölkerung in Russland gewährt
irgendwann auch mal auf und sagt so pass
auf jetzt ist aber langsam gut wir haben
jetzt 300.000 Soldaten die er da geholt
hat das sind alles junge Leute ja
die haben Eltern ja und ob die das so
lustig finden wenn ihre Kinder nicht
mehr nach Hause kommen glaube ich auch
nicht und ich glaube auch dann fällt
diese russische Propaganda mal das ist
so eine der Möglichkeiten die man ja im
Auge behalten muss was den Krieg beenden
kann beziehungsweise die
Gesprächsbereitschaft von einem Putin
und von deiner Frau vielleicht ein wenig
passiert weil wenn man das sieht wir
haben Frau bärbock gehabt er darf auch
kommt rein hält seine Rede dreht Strom
geht wieder ja das ist eine Art und
Weise diplomatisch gesehen
also unmöglich wäre da noch wer da noch
gestrahlt oder geprahlt das letzte das
geht überhaupt gar nicht ja die sind
nicht gesprächsbereit also wie schaffe
ich das Gespräch
erreicht jetzt kommt noch schwedene
Fingern in die NATO auch schlecht für
Russland gut für unsere baltischen
Freunde okay jetzt ist eben nicht und er
hat keinen seiner Christina erreicht
trotzdem darf man nicht vergessen
Russland ist die zweitgrößerung Macht
der Welt dem Putin sein Soldaten leider
schnurz die Opposition ist mutig aber
die meisten sind knasten werden
unterdrückt und ob die Diktatur so
schnell fällt das weiß ich nicht ich
hoffe Sie haben Recht
ich habe die Angst nicht dass der
putinator sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich
ich glaube damit arbeitet er jetzt schon
seit Jahren ich kann ich ich will auch
gar nicht sprechen
davon ab bei unserem Wohlstand bei ihrem
wohlstandsversprechen gewesen und ich
will ein Brot auf diesen Tisch legt weiß
jemand in diesen Tagen was Brot kostet
der Bartsch Leib Brot was zahlen sie im
Moment dafür was dieses Brot können zum
Beispiel diese
da das wird irgendwie so bei 3,60 €
Kosten vielleicht auch
4,3,60 € Ende 3 Euro im Moment bei
diesem kleinen Leib
rot.minister aus Nordrhein-Westfalen hat
gesagt wir werden dann kurz über 8 €
liegen wird es ein Luxusgut er ist dafür
kein Luxusgut werden schauen Sie Herr
Laumann und ich wir können uns das
locker ja deswegen muss man dort etwas
tun deswegen sage ich bei diesem zum
Beispiel ist hier das Thema bei
Grundnahrungsmittel ob man die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Null nimmt es muss
gehandelt werden dass der Punkt oder
gibt es mehrere Stränge es ist doch
nicht so niemand in der Politik hat
jetzt den Knopf und sagt das machen wir
das alles gut das wird ein Prozess sein
und da sind Fehler in der Vergangenheit
gemacht worden aber jetzt werden aktuell
in der Gegenwart zu viel Fehler gemacht
denn wenn wir so weiter tun und das
machen wir aktuell wird die Inflation
bald bei 10% sein und der Leib rot wird
noch teurer werden so und das können
sich wir hier alle Leisten aber es gibt
jetzt doch schon die Eltern die sagen
ich kann meinem Kind kein Eis kaufen da
haben wir noch ein Problem und deswegen
sage ich das auf der anderen Seite die
gibt die milliardenschiffe in dieser
Zeit und im übrigen verdienen sogar
Menschen auch an den Waffen die wir
liefern da finde ich muss man einen Teil
abholen das ist dringend notwendig dann
kriegen wir auch sozialen Ausgleich hin
ansonsten kann es so sein dass genau der
sehr gefährdet ist der soziale
Zusammenarbeit das will hier vermutlich
niemand also ihr auch auch Herr dörvel
nicht den
sozialen Steuer oben drauf und so weiter
um es denen die Arbeiten gehen und es
nicht ganz so dicke haben den Alltag
überhaupt bezahlbares um den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland zu
ruinieren das sind ja mittelständische
Unternehmer von dem wir reden
Arbeitsplätze geschaffen haben all das
sind substanzsteuern also mit anderen
Worten da werden werkzeilen besteuert in
dem Menschen arbeiten aber ökonomischer
Quatsch aber was man natürlich machen
muss ist die Preise Unterbringen der
Grund warum Christian Lindner am
Wochenende von der gaspreisbremse
gesprochen hat ist doch genau der dass
das mit den 8 Euro nicht passiert
insofern ist das der Grund warum
unfassbar teuer ist und das wollen wir
runterbringen und auf der anderen Seite
die Kapazitäten ausweiten wir haben das
jetzt alles diskutiert das Ziel muss
sein das Wurzel bei der Übel bei dass
das Übel bei der Wurzel zu packen nicht
im Nachhinein den Schaden entstehen zu
lassen Dietmar Bartsch wäre
wahrscheinlich da der vorschlagen und
dann über sozialen Ausgleich sondern von
Anfang an das Problem minimieren
gehen in diesen Herbst und Winter und
bauen
wärmehallen wo sich die Menschen mit
Decken wärmen können in diesem Winter
das ist im Moment machen
Land wie Deutschland das nicht kann wir
haben das bei Corona gezeigt mit dem
Kurzarbeitergeld zum Beispiel wo wir
eine Menge für Geld ausgegeben haben
wenn dann wie Deutschland wer soll das
denn eigentlich hinbekommen wir werden
das schaffen wir werden das schaffen und
müssen das auch hinkriegen und ich bin
sicher wir werden das auch zusammen
hinkriegen da wird sich jeder
kompromissmäßig bewegen müssen so ist
das aber am Ende wird es Vorschläge
geben das darf nicht 8 Euro kosten das
können die Leute sich nämlich nicht mehr
leisten und das kann nicht das Ergebnis
sein denn sonst holen sie nämlich die
Rechtsradikalen Abschlussfrage ja oder
nein Herr Schäfer sie sind vom Fach
werden wir in diesem Herbst Winter ein
Blackout erleben in Deutschland aus weil
es ist halt sehr viel passiert im
Bereich der Heizung weil die Heizungen
halt eben jetzt alle umgerüstet werden
auf Wärmepumpen energiefachberater
gemacht werden wird spannend werden wir
ein schleckerhaut Erleben sagt er ich
danke ganz herzlich an die Runde Herr
Stegner herr Schäfer Herr steinhöfe und
steht schauen einmal noch rein bevor wir
uns nächsten Montag um 22:15 Uhr
Wiedersehen in das war's der
unionsfraktionschef der CDU Chef
Friedrich Merz gesagt hat zu haben wir
die falsche Regierung
Herr Merz vor einem Jahr war
Bundestagswahl wenn die Wähler an dem
Abend an dem Tag gewusst hätten was an
Gasrechnungen Stromrechnung auf sie
zukommt wäre die Regierung im Amt heute
also vermutlich hätten wir ein anderes
Wahlergebnis bekommen wenn die Welle die
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Deutschland
auch nur einen Hauch einer Ahnung gehabt
hätten wie wir regiert werden dann hätte
es dieses Wahlergebnis nicht gegeben er
hat davon auszugehen dass mit ihnen die
Gasrechnung in Deutschland heute
niedriger werden wir hätten die
Angebotsseite klargestellt wir hätten
auf diesen angebotsschock mit einer
Ausweitung des Angebotes reagiert und
wir hätten über den Sommer neben der
verstrumpfung von Biomasse neben den
Kohlekraftwerken aus Steinkohle und
Braunkohle auch die Kernkraftwerke
sichergestellt dass sie laufen und zwar
nicht nur im streckbetrieb sondern auch
mit neuen Brennstäben man muss doch in
einer solchen Situation jede Quelle
nutzen die man hat um Energie zu
erzeugen wir verstromen immer noch Gas
in Deutschland wenig aber für Strom noch
Gas das hätten wir sicherlich so nicht
akzeptiert diejenigen die arbeiten hart
arbeiten Steuern zahlen von denen können
sich ganz viele die Heizung zu Hause
sich leisten während das Flüchtlingen
und Hartz IV Empfängern seid ihr ganz
vielen Jahren bezahlt wird die warme
Wohnung ist das ungerecht das ist
ungerecht und das wird auch von den
Menschen zu Recht als ungerecht
empfunden und zu allem setzt die
Bundesregierung noch die Krone auf indem
sie jetzt dieses neue Bürgergeld
einführt das wird uns in den nächsten
drei Jahren mindestens 20 Milliarden
Euro kosten wir hätten dieses Bürgergeld
in dieser Form nicht eingeführt wir
hätten das Prinzip fordern und fördern
beibehalten es macht keinen Sinn
Menschen die schon in der
Arbeitslosigkeit sind und jetzt noch mal
Bürgergeld hinten drauf bekommen sechs
Monate alle Freiheiten zu geben sich
nicht um ihren Job kümmern zu müssen
also hier werden schwere Fehler gemacht
die wir auch in den nächsten Jahren noch
in ihren Auswirkungen und zwar auch dann
sehen wir die Energiekrise hoffentlich
längst vorbei ist rechnen Sie in diesem
Herbst Winter mit Blackouts in
Deutschland ist das dann ein Scholz
Blackout
in dieser Situation
müsste doch eigentlich der Bundeskanzler
in der Lage sein diese Regierung
zusammenzuhalten und zu führen wo ist
eigentlich der Bundeskanzler hat der
eigentlich zu diesen Themen auch eine
Meinung oder überlässt er erst im
Finanzminister und dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister naja aber man
kann auch mit Corona und vor Corona sich
mal zur Sache äußern man kann mal ein
Kabinett zusammenhalten wir erleben
jetzt wochenlange Streitereien dieser
Koalition und ein Bundeskanzler der sich
zu diesen Themen nicht äußert der keine
Regierungserklärung abgibt der im
Parlament nicht auftaucht also dies ist
eine Krise der Regierung und dies wird
eine Krise des Bundeskanzlers Blackout
ist ja nicht irgendwas sondern es ist
schlicht dunkel dann für eine Zeit in
Deutschland das wäre vor vor einem Jahr
noch völlig undenkbar gewesen kann eine
Regierung sowas durchhalten Blackout in
Deutschland also lassen wir uns mal nur
auf wenige Minuten Stromausfall oder
vielleicht einige Stunden Stromausfall
die hiesige Bürgermeisterin hält das ja
für verträglich lassen Sie mal drei
Stunden in den kl in Berlin den
stromausfallen oder in den großen
Kühlhäusern den stromausfallen wir
werden schon nach einer Stunde
Stromausfall merken welchen
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden das
anrichtet wir können uns das in diesem
Land nicht leisten und wir müssten es
auch nicht akzeptieren wenn wir eine
bessere Regierung also das stünde in der
Verantwortung der Regierung das steht
allein in der Verantwortung dieser
Regierung die wertvollste Zeit vertan
hat mit Streitereien ohne die Probleme
wirklich zu lösen und überhaupt in
Krisen muss man dann mit einer
restriktiveren Flüchtlingspolitik
arbeiten wir sehen mit großer Besorgnis
dass die Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung
vom System der asylbewerberleistung auf
das System der Arbeitslosengeld 2
Zahlungen überzugehen im Frühjahr zu
erheblichen Verwerfungen auch bei den
Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine führt wir
erleben mittlerweile einen
sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge
nach Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine
mehr als 1,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge
insgesamt bisher den Stand heute eine
größere Zahl sich dieses System zu Nutze
machen da haben wir ein Problem das wird
größer wir haben im Frühjahr darauf
hingewiesen dass dieses Problem
entstehen konnte die Bundesregierung hat
sich taub gestellt und muss man also in
diesem besonderen Krisenzeiten in der
Flüchtlingspolitik noch strenger sein
bei der Aufnahme ich finde wir sind in
der ganzen Einwanderungspolitik in
Deutschland seit längerer Zeit nicht
wirklich konsistent wir brauchen auf der
einen Seite Fachkräfte nach Deutschland
aber wir müssen auf der anderen Seite
dafür sorgen dass die Zahl derer die
nach Deutschland kommen und hier auf
Zeit oder auf Dauer bleiben
striktbegrenzt werden und dass du die
Bundesregierung nicht im Gegenteil sie
ruft nun mittlerweile dazu auf dass alle
nach Deutschland kommen die hierher
gerne kommen würden das ist mit
Sicherheit der falsche Weg und das löst
im übrigen soziale Spannungen aus die
wir uns in diesem Lande wirklich
ersparen sollten wenn diese Regierung
crasht
in ihrem eigentlichen Zeit vor den vier
Jahren sind sie Standby könnten sie
heute übernehmen die Opposition von
heute ist immer die Regierung von morgen
aber wir arbeiten nicht auf den Crash
dieser Regierung wenn es nötig wäre
wären wir selbstverständlich in der Lage
zu übernehmen das ist überhaupt keine
Frage aber noch einmal wir müssen in der
gegenwärtigen Situation ein gemeinsames
Interesse daran haben dass dieses Land
gut regiert wird ich habe allerdings
Zweifel wenn eine Regierung und ein
Bundeskanzler noch nicht einmal in der
Lage ist seine eigene Regierung
zusammenzuhalten dann wird da wenig Zeit
darauf verwenden können noch andere mit
ins Boot zu nehmen
[Musik]